that's what we're going for
sign me up
talk about the mr cap mushroom play that
you just announced obviously uh you know
i feel like
psilocybin is the future yeah it's it's
definitely uh i don't know how legal it
is in canada it might be all the way
legal but in terms of just like the
legality of psilocybin in the united
states i feel like it's coming yeah yeah
it's like how we was there's like
lobbyists fighting for it and there's
places where it's legal and then there's
places where they're just like right now
it's like colorado i think portland
portland yeah portland portland as well
but it's not legal enough to [ __ ]
sell
uh psilocybin so
we're not doing that in in the us i'm
like you see a lot of shrooms you see a
lot of like bar uh chocolates and pills
and [ __ ] like that like that shit's not
technically you know
it's not
you know
you know what i'm saying not legal or
not i didn't say it but it's definitely
not legal yeah uh but
a lot of people are you know they're
mixing it and they're they're figuring
out ways to do it without the psilocybin
so like there's mushrooms that are like
kind of herbal you can grow them now
like they're making your own at-home
grow kids so when it does you know what
i mean people are already going to be
and they're doing this overseas and
there's places that and that's why we're
getting tapped in with mr cash because
there's places that i'm gonna be able to
like go full on with it and then there's
gonna be places where it's like a little
bit what's the us version of mr capps
going to be you'll see okay but that's
what i'm telling you there's going to be
a difference to save my ass so if i go
to amsterdam i might get some [ __ ] there
you go yeah there you go now we talking
have you ever had a terrible trip
no i've i i wouldn't say terrible but
it's been pretty intense like mushrooms
to me is like a roller coaster like you
go up you get like really [ __ ] scared
and then like you drop and then it's
like intense and then you cruise for a
little bit and then it gets [ __ ]
intense again like whatever it might be
a loop a turn or whatever it is that's
how i literally got through rolling loud
just by eating shrooms the whole time
yeah but how much did you eat though uh
probably let's see throughout the week
we went through like two or three
eighths no three three eighths that's a
lot yeah we ate a lot it was me and this
guy right in a week yeah
dude trust me everything was real
realistic the whole the whole
[ __ ] miami trip was see
i don't know that mushrooms i was at
booby trap
truman truman roomy trap